Un pays va devenir malgré lui l'enjeu entre Occidentaux et Russes.
Il s'agit de l'Ukraine.
En décembre 2004, les résultats de l'élection présidentielle en Ukraine sont contestés.
2 candidats, le président sortant, Iouchtchenko, qui regarde vers Moscou et a le soutien de Vladimir Poutine,
et son opposant, Ianoukovitch, qui a le soutien des Américains et Européens
et qui souhaite intégrer l'OTAN et l'Europe.
Le candidat de Vladimir Poutine est déclaré vainqueur.
Il s'ensuit un mouvement de protestation appelé la Révolution orange.
Pendant 10 ans,
l'Ukraine reste divisée entre des provinces pro-Russes et d'autres qui rêvent de l'Europe de Bruxelles.
10 ans plus tard, la crise atteint son paroxysme lorsque Ianoukovitch,
devenu président et hier allié des Européens,
refuse d'entériner l'accord d'association passé entre son pays et Bruxelles,
préférant traiter avec Moscou.
Les Ukrainiens favorables à une entrée dans l'Union européenne
crient à la trahison et font le siège du Parlement.
Le 12 février 2015,
les responsables politiques français et allemands se mettent autour de la table avec Vladimir Poutine
pour trouver une solution pacifique au conflit ukrainien.
L'échange entre Angela Merkel et Vladimir Poutine pendant cette réunion au sommet
témoigne du mépris du dirigeant russe pour les Européens.
- Nous sommes là, donc les 4 dirigeants, plus les ministres des Affaires étrangères, plus quelques collaborateurs,
une pièce fermée.
Et vers 4h du matin, je pense, donc difficile, on discute ligne à ligne.
Tout d'un coup, la chancelière Merkel, qui pourtant est une femme très patiente, est excédée.
Et dans mon souvenir, elle sort une photo
où on voit un gradé russe qui est visiblement en territoire ukrainien,
dans ce qu'on appelle le Donbass, et elle le montre à Poutine,
le général ou le colonel russe, il s'appelle je sais pas comment.
Et lui dit : "Vladimir, tu dis qu'il n'y a pas de troupes russes, mais le colonel, etc. ?"
Et Poutine, sans perdre une seconde et sans se départir de son calme,
répond : "Il a dû probablement perdre son chemin".
Vladimir Poutine sera-t-il l'homme qui prolongera les ambitions gaulliennes,
qui voulaient construire une Europe de l'Atlantique à l'Oural ?
Aujourd'hui, il doit affronter la défiance des Occidentaux.
Pourtant, lors de leur accession au pouvoir,
le maître du Kremlin et son Premier ministre Medvedev
étaient très favorables à un rapprochement avec leurs voisins européens.
- Medvedev, quand il a été président, était spécialement coopératif, trop aux yeux de Poutine.
Mais bon, quand même, y a une période.
Donc y a une période Poutine 1, Poutine 2, Medvedev, pendant lesquelles...
En tout cas, moi, je fais partie
de ceux qui considèrent que l'Occident aurait dû être plus intelligent,
ferme, dissuasif, mais plus coopératif.
Après, on a Poutine 3, quand il revient.
Et là, y a une alliance nouvelle avec l'Eglise orthodoxe
et la Russie prend un ton beaucoup plus agressif.
"Premièrement, la Russie paillasson, c'est terminé, et je vais montrer", dit Poutine,
"aux Occidentaux que j'ai un pouvoir de blocage dans plusieurs domaines
"et qu'on ne peut pas se passer de moi."